台股週五暴漲3186點
原本想說紙商可以拿來回收了嗎
恐怕先別急
因為週五台紙期夜盤
又跳水下錯了1077點
就讓不少股民苦嘆
難道週一又要再度回公園了嗎
明明受到科技財報利多
週五每股四大指數都收紅
怎麼台股夜盤卻逆勢重挫
最低還一度要跌破4萬2
沒乘週五反彈人到走廊逃命
周一是否真要挖擂蛋
想必周五才刚因为一亿零零五零
账面大赚超过一千万却没卖的郭哲荣
肯定要被关心几句
我上次真的完全不担心
我睡得蛮好的
礼拜一我觉得会稍微开低一些
但可能不一定想大家想那么严重
要选择可以睡得到的部位
如果那你睡不好的部位
那呆睫毛就睫毛或者心态要改变
点出风涨后回档很正常
基本面没出现重大转折
就不该脑冲乱砍
而是要太弱补强
有机会开地走高
我觉得明天有机会跌点收敛
甚至跌点到500点是300点以内
甚至有机会挑战旁冲翻红
当然我觉得这边拉回
我觉得稍微进场做多
不过也有投资人抱怨
很常跌停想止损挂卖却卖不掉
其实是因为不少被打成
儲置股 觀禁幣 延遲交易
就讓王世堅開批
30年前台股所適用儲置制度
跟目前市場根本嚴重脫節
因為政府的儲置
導致它賣不掉
讓它跌得更深的時候
那股民他們的怨嘆
當然怪罪的對象
唯一就是怪罪政府
認為應該用熔斷機制
取代分盤交易
不該干預市場流動性
點出在股市震盪時政府不送暖
至少也別再添亂
都是很鹿鞋的林豪榮李仁峰
台北參謀道
攝影師起來起來
快看手機
台股31號迎來3186點
驚天暴漲
來來來
公園解散今晚家菜
折折道歉表也拿去
因為他是不是
幾天前就跟你說過這一句
好我接受你的道歉
但是请记得我名言
All in 中押就现在
社群狂被洗版不是没原因
投顾老师郭哲荣
在台股五个交易日
跌掉近5000点时
30号这些话你有没有听
我恳求你们
再给自己最后一次
爱哲哲的机会
现在买All in 现金
All in 全押
我知道你还有钱
叫人家O-IN更要以身作折
自稱螳螂黨局
29號直接砸1億買0050這精神狀態團结信心信心记忆记忆我希望你们通通踏着我的雪前进
是的
哲哲团长这回真胜利
晒队账单29号0050分别买在93.45元和93.2元
共1100张成本约1.02亿
31号0050直接涨停
今天涨停板10%刚好就是赚1000万
对比两天前衣服红了
红酒开了
当时当掉的表也回来了
一战成名
直播观看人数比平常多了四到五倍
这个我一次爱哲哲的机会
男粉丝其实很多喜欢另外一句名言
就是说反正命一条冲就对了
不过从盘面看反弹三千多点
量却只有八千多亿
就有另一派分析师直言
这是开人道走廊
三千多点恐怕下周就土回去
而对于刚赚一千万的哲哲来说
还是只有这一句
今年就会上五万点
明年突破6万点
然后4到5年内突破10万点
东盛轮鞋零和红台北从不得
太阳高高挂阳光耀眼照得红彤彤
台股也一扫阴霾狂亮红灯
IC设计龙头连发科气势如虹
在法说会前夕冲涨停
神山台积电更一度占上2400
上涨195点
广达鸿海涨幅也多4%以上
台股大盘在7月最后一个交易日
盘中涨了将近3000点
超越今年5月4号
写下史上盘中最大涨点
市值一下增加超过9兆元
解铃还需细铃人
今天韩国它涨到垄断
带动整个雅谷的一个反弹
台股这一波的融资予额
也轻了蛮多的出来
4900亿左右
也低于5000亿
今天的报复性反弹
我想延续两到三天的机会是有的
满血复活的还有还有
前两天重挫的族群
像是记忆体的南亚科
华邦店 利基店 旺宏
早盘同步攻上涨停
载版三雄 星星南店
和景硕也都红彤彤
至于差一点完成圣诞树的
被动元件龙头国具
也亮灯涨停 跳回五字头
而ETF腰石金木也回来了
00981A和00991A也一度涨停
盘面气氛明显回温
像CCL或者载版
他们的试况还是明显的今年都还是供不应求的情况
甚至个股他们越跌本益比越好
那这样的话可以去做持股续报
甚至有拉回再做加码的动作
因为大盘涨而跟着涨
然后再去找他涨价新闻的一些个股族群的话
可能就不一样了
比如说像公立元件或者说是其他称光的族群
觀察事況AI產業訂單
在沒有砍單 沒有取消
也沒有遞延情況下
基本面持續看多太鼓不但一吐怨氣還能繼續揚眉吐氣東森採集新聞保照片留言在台語道
有沒有 它居然是什麼
拍槓桿之外
然後全民封股市就股市爆倉
然後勒 央行居然再來一個升息
直接抽水 後真的是太鬧了
但是OK 這些的種種的因素
似乎已經進入到了
那個不確定性逐漸解除的一個狀態
所以台股這邊受到國際股市的影響
我覺得也開始有些回穩的跡象
那這邊當然台股這過去兩天
過去兩三天的時間
是測試到半年線的位置
半年線守住
今天再來一個跳空開高
當然比較可惜的就是什麼
早上跟朋友在講
如果昨天賣掉的
再看到今天又買不回來
其實就是雙重打擊
但是OK
我覺得還是冷靜下來
到這邊怎麼去做一個操作
其實很簡單的狀況
半年線守住
我認為大概沒什麼太大問題
但是因為季線是一個生命線
季線仍然在上方
所以你說會忽然V轉就創高
我覺得這個機率也沒這麼高
但是也因為跌到這邊
其實我覺得很多的投資價值
已經浮現了
所以操作上我會建議說
以超跌的全資股為主
那當然我們隨便舉例
以全貿台積電來看的話
台積電其實一般券商
今年已經來到大概109元
20倍本盈比大概2180左右
所以其實我覺得
靠近這個位置都是一個不錯的位階
當然今天跳空開高
居然漲了8%多
又重新回到季線
那我覺得2180到2330之間
大概都是一個可以持續布局的位置
那當然從台積電延伸出來
就是我們講三台柱
台積電 台達電 台光電
其實這三檔我覺得都維持一個高成長
這倒是沒什麼太大問題
那當然台達電也是全球電源的龍頭
那這邊其實在進入到AI的時代
越來越AI伺服器越來越進步的狀況
那對於熱的管理
這一塊是非常重要的
當然包含熱的管理跟電源的管理
所以這些大概都是趨勢上
另外在老AI的族群部分
因為像這個老AI的族群
鴻海廣達偽創等等的
其實已經趴在地上很久了
然後廣達昨天還因為什麼
要募資的事情
還殺了一根跌停板
但是坦白說到這個位階
我覺得本一筆都是相對的低
所以如果你擔心說股市的波動過大的話
我覺得老AI的族群
算是相對低的位階的個股
然後另外封測族群
就是我們套一句
為了董事長的話
先進封裝產能就是
不夠不夠還是不夠
所以在這個我們講封測的產業我覺得也沒有什麼太大問題那當然月光今天是一架說是掌停但是坦白說已經跌到這個位階了就算不掌停
我覺得明後天打開
就下禮拜一打開的話
我覺得都還是有佈局的機會
那如果有機會站回到季縣
其實再向上挑戰的機會
也都是有的
所以這些我覺得都是一些
相對安穩的固域
那當然如果比較受到
觀眾比較青睞的
或者說比較關心的
我想應該是在
被動元件的部分
被動元件
那這邊當然龍頭國巨
大家都說
買到國巨來生再聚
但是這個地方
我覺得也不要過度擔心
因為像大家
也很關心的什麼
姚之金母
00981A
昨天也是繼續買
那麼當然在這個地方
我覺得一個重點是什麼
昨天外資回頭買超過
6347張
我記得昨天換算一下
大概是將近29億左右
甚至应该更高
因为等于还是有稍微跌下去的
那买进这么多的金额的话
我相信也不是在开玩笑
所以你说国际的状况
大家都会说国际是不是什么
老板卖股票了
第一个老板曾经说没有嘛
然后再来这一波
我觉得其实是筹码面多杀多的因素影响
好马上来关注台股在本周接连重挫之后
今天7月最后一天是展开绝地大反攻
早盘开盘就强谈超过2700点
指数拼回4万2000点的大关
台币也跟随转身
那最新的行情
马上把时间带来平均
好的
我们帮大家看到
这些台北股市
有机会来创下
史上第一大的涨点记录
如果目前
涨2700点能够维系到收盘的话
就会创历史最大涨点记录了
那今天台北股市之所以会
绝地大反攻
是因为昨天的美国股市
传来蛮多好消息的
包含了这波跌很深的费万指数
昨天狂飙8%
微软的好财报
终于给美股的科技股
打了一技抢
新增水微软
领军就狂飙了有15%
另外一个讯息是
川普也宣布达成了协议
哈马斯要全面的解除武装
以色列军队随后就撤离加萨
所以地缘相关政治的一个疑虑
也在今天盘面当中小米了
还有就是韩国股市
也是这波去杠杆的重灾
去兼早盘狂飙超过14%
SK海力社会长崔泰元
要砸331万美元增持股票
三星电子也要重启
股东的回报计划
今天给了韩国股市很强力的支撑
所以在台北股市这一波融资
在这个礼拜狂减800多亿之后
融资减幅已经超越了大盘跌幅
这算是一个落地讯号
今天开盘指数就是狂飙超过一度
接近2900点
那么在今天涨停满有超过150档
刚刚连981A 991A都一度亮灯涨停
台剑涨的170块台达电联发哥也一度亮灯
跌深的被动元件
记忆体细晶元等等族群
其实今天有非常多档股票
今天都来到了亮灯掌停板
他就要观察了这个强谈气势
有没有办法延续到下周
以上是今天台股的一个最新变化
再把宣传给朋友们